[Music]
we're really glad that all of you could
make it hope you're enjoying cloud next
2019
now over the past few years you've heard
us talk a lot about how Google cloud is
built on top of our global network
infrastructure this year we wanted to
take the opportunity opportunity to dive
deeper into this aspect of the global
network design talk about how it enables
features in global virtual networks or V
pcs and hopefully encourage you to think
big and to think global when you're
planning for your own application
deployments we have a 50 minute talk
today my name is Neha button and I'm a
software engineer at Google I'm going to
be joined by Marshall Vail who is a
product manager on the cloud DNS team
and by Ed Hammond who is the senior
Enterprise Architect on the cardinal
health team and he's going to be sharing
with us the inside scoop on how cardinal
health deploys VP C's so this is
basically what cloud consists of cloud
is divided into regions which further
gets subdivided into zones now a region
is a geographic location in a certain
continent where the round-trip time or
the RTT from one VM to another is
typically under one millisecond a region
is typically divided into three or four
zones and a zone is a geography location
within a region which is which has its
own fully isolated and independent
failure domain and so no two machines
that are in different zones or in
different regions share the same fate
when it comes to failure so they're in
definitely in different data centers in
GCP at this time we have 19 regions and
58 zones so how does Google's network
infrastructure power this now Google's
network infrastructure basically
consists of three main types of networks
the first is the data center network
this is what connects all the machines
in a data center together the second is
a software based private van that we
call before that connects all the data
centers together and the third is also
an SDN based public van for use of
facing traffic and
our network so a machine basically gets
connected from the internet via the
public man and gets connected to other
machines in other data centers over the
private fan so when you send a packet
from your virtual machine running in
cloud let's say in North America to a
GCS bucket running in Asia for example
then the packet doesn't leave the
network backbone it basically doesn't
traverse over the Internet it traverses
over Google's Network now one of the
things that I would like to mention here
is that in addition to the peering
routers at the edge of our network we
also deploy network load balancers and
layer seven reverse proxies the layer
seven reverse proxies basically help us
in terminating the users TCP or SSL
connection and a location closest to the
user now this is really important
because as you know establishing an
HTTPS connection requires two network
round trips between the client and the
server and so it's really important to
reduce the RTT between the client and
the server and we do this by bringing
the server closer to the client and so
we basically terminate the end users TCP
or SSL connection at a location that is
closest to the end-user so this is
basically what comprises the global
Google Network with 134 network edge
locations presence in over 200 countries
and territories and content delivered
through Google cloud CDN you get access
to the same functionality that also
powers all of Google services like
search maps Gmail YouTube each of these
are used by over a billion users
worldwide this is a snapshot of our
footprint in GCP as I mentioned before
we have 19 regions we have also
announced two new regions that will be
turning up before the end of this year
so we are turning up regions in Japan
and South Korea this year before the end
of next year will also be turning up two
more regions in Salt Lake City in USA
and in Jakarta and Indonesia
as I mentioned before we have 134 pops
or points of presence and 96 CDN
locations our data centers are connected
to each other through hundreds of
thousands of miles of fiber optic cable
they also have 13 sub C cable
investments we have 81 inter connect
locations so these are basically sites
where you can physically appear with us
directly in order to use either
dedicated or partner interconnect so via
saul of this important to you why do you
care that the network is actually global
now if you were to deploy your
applications you would do so by
deploying the applications to multiple
VMs in a single zone in order to protect
yourself against single VM or single
machine failures in order to protect
yourself against single zone failures
you can replicate your application
across multiple zones in the region so
this basically gives you added
redundancy and so increases the
availability of your application in
order to further protect yourself
against regional outages so things like
natural disasters or other such rare
events you can then replicate your
application across multiple regions and
this is how you get a global deployment
now what is critical here is that with
global deployments you are assured that
all the traffic stays on Google's
network backbone and does not leave
Google's network backbone so you get
access to all of your compute and
storage resources globally and privately
which means that you don't need to
assign public IP s to your VMs
and you don't need to set up expensive
VPN or peering connections in order to
stitch regional V pcs together now
another way of designing for robustness
is to use load balancing due to the
global nature of Google's network we are
able to offer global load balancing so
that you get a global IP address
assigned to your load balanced
application so a user in Taiwan sees the
same global IP address for your
application as a user in Texas and they
both get routed to the closest healthy
backends so the user in Texas may get
routed to the closest healthy back-end
that may be running in Portland Oregon
but if there are no healthy backends
that are running in any region in North
America they may get routed to the next
closest healthy back-end which may be
across the Atlantic but the important
thing here is that the end users TCP or
SSL connection will get terminated close
to the location of the user before
getting encrypted and then routed over
the Google Network backbone to the data
center in Europe we use the same DDoS
protection system in cloud as we do for
the rest of Google and so you benefit
from the same parameter security that
the rest of Google services have we are
able to assign a single global IP
address to our load-balanced
applications using stabilized any cost
now any cost is many of you would know
is an addressing and routing methodology
that allows you to route data grams from
from a single sender to the receiver
that is closest to the sender among a
set of multiple receivers that are all
programmed to surf traffic and to
receive traffic on the same IP address
the you stabilized any cost in order to
preserve the TCP session despite BGP
instability so if an end users is B is
recalculating
the routes in that they are announcing
then there may be certain amount of
instability in the TCP sessions that the
end user experiences as a result of this
the end users request may get routed to
a network load balancer in a location
that is not closest to the end user now
when this happens the network load
balancer in that location figures out
that the client IP is actually closer to
a different location and then forwards
that request to that location so this is
how we basically preserve TCP session
stability despite bgp instability so
that's all about the physical network
how does this enable features in the
global network in the virtual network so
as you know virtual networks or V pcs in
Google cloud are global in nature so you
can create your network once you can
associate network
policies once in your network so things
like firewall rules and routing policies
can be applied once to your network and
these policies will work seamlessly as
you expand to multiple regions and you
place your computer resources in new
regions if you're an enterprise network
administrator then you can use share BBC
in order to centrally create and manage
your network while allowing full
autonomy to your developers and allowing
your organization to scale to hundreds
or even thousands of developers or
development teams so let's take a look
at an example now let's say in your
organization you would like to create
two types of applications one is web
application that is internet facing and
the other is a billing application that
is not facing the internet that share
VPC you can create a load balancer in
your web app project for reasons that we
discussed earlier you will want to
create redundancy and so you create
compute resources in multiple regions
and then you can set these as backends
of your load balancer you can then
create internal load balanced
applications inside the billing project
and you can use your billing backends as
billing VMs as backends to these
internal load balancers and thus you can
create multiple tiers of applications in
your shared EPC you can then associate
firewall rules within the VPC in order
to restrict traffic due to the global
nature of a network you also get access
to Google managed API services privately
which means that you don't need to
assign public IP addresses to your VMs
in order to access API services like
your cloud storage machine learning
BigTable spanner and many others this
functionality of privately accessing
Google managed API services is now
extended to the on-prem so that you are
able to access Google managed API
services privately from your on-prem
network by a VPN or interconnect in
order to secure your VPC you can use
network layer firewall rules net
their firewall rules are stateful and
connection tracked now you can create
allow or deny firewall rules either in
the ingress or the ingress direction by
specifying source IP ranges or
destination IP ranges you can also use
tags or service accounts in order to
easily group resources that you are
applying firewall rules on now another
really important feature is enable and
disable firewall rules this is something
that we have launched in the past year
so if you're troubleshooting your
network and you would like to find out
the root cause of an issue by
temporarily disabling a firewall rule
and seeing what the effect it has on the
network then now you don't have to
delete the firewall rule and recreate it
you can simply disable and then
re-enable the firewall rule another
really important feature that we have
launched to GA over the past year is
firewall logging firewall locking
basically allows you to see reports of
connection records that get created for
every time a firewall rule gets applied
on a connection firewall dogs are not
sampled unlike vbc flow logs but there
is a limit on the number of connections
records that get exported in a
five-second interval and this limit
depends on your machine size firewall
logs get exported to the shared EPC host
project so that the security
administrator of your organization can
view the firewall rules and verify that
the firewall rules in in the
organization are administered and are
getting applied correctly you can export
far belongs to stackdriver cloud pub/sub
cloud storage or bigquery now as I
mentioned far more logs consists of
connection records where a connection
record gets created every time a
firewall rule gets applied so for VM to
VM traffic there would be a connection
record that's that gets created for the
increase rule on the sender VM and for
the increase rule that gets applied on
the receiver VM this is also true for VM
to VM traffic in the V PC even if even
if the VMS belong to multiple service
projects
and for traffic that is entering or
leaving your VPC either to go to a
shared vp either to go to a peered VPC
to go to the internet or to go to your
on-prem through a VPN connection now if
you would like to apply security
policies at the edge of our network then
you can do so by clicking a ting
security policies using cloud armor and
what this allows you to do is to specify
the rules that should get applied at the
edge so this is perimeter security that
gets applied on your load-balanced
applications so let's say you create a
load-balanced application you can now
associate security policies using cloud
armor with the load balancer and this
assures that the traffic that is
permitted on to the load-balanced
application will conform with the rules
that you've specified so your VMs
basically don't see traffic from from
the sender's that you have blacklisted
you can specify cloud armored rules
using IP blacklists or white lists these
this set of rules this functionality is
basically generally available now you
can also specify the rules using vassals
or geo specific rules or you can use a
flexible rules language in order to
customize the rules that you would like
to specify so what does a typical
deployment look like now in a typical
deployment you would create an HTTP or
HTTPS load balancer this is a global
load balanced application and you would
automatically get defense against DDoS
attacks this is because at the edge we
implement the DDoS protection and so any
traffic that is entering your network
will get DDoS attacks defense for free
if you would like to apply custom rules
for your load load balanced application
then you can use cloud armor and you can
associate the cloud armor security
policy with your load balancer if you
would like to allow access to your load
balanced application only for users that
have been granted this access using ion
policies then you can use a product
called cloud I
that's short for identity of where proxy
so what the identity of where proxy does
is that it checks whether the end users
credentials have it will check these and
use those credentials against I am
policy and it will check whether the end
user has been granted I am access to
this load-balancing load-balancing
application and if it has then it will
allow the for the traffic to come in so
traffic will basically enter your V PC
it will be received by the VMS only if
it has allowed both by cloud Armour as
well as the identity of web proxy within
the V PC you can use network layer
firewall rules to specify the security
on your VMs and you can specify them so
that you are allowing traffic only from
the load balancer proxy and you don't
have to open your VMs or your ports on
the VMS to the internet another really
important aspect of design of security
design is ensuring that you mitigate the
risk of data exfiltration you can do
this now using BBC service controls so
that you define a service parameter or a
security perimeter outside of which your
data should not be accessible or it
should not be allowed to be copy with
the functionality of allowing private
access to Google services from your
on-prem network via VPN or interconnects
the definition of your security
parameter can also be extended to your
on-prem so that brings us to the next
question how do you access on-prem now
there are multiple ways of connecting
your virtual network running in the
cloud to your on-prem network you can do
so using VPN and you can either
configure VPN using static routes or you
can use cloud router in order to
dynamically exchange routes using bgp or
you can use interconnect in which case
you are directly peering with us and you
can use either dedicated interconnect
where you control the peering or you can
use partner interconnect where you are
paying a partner for where the partner
is basically peering with us and
paying them for the bandwidth that you
use you can create VPN connections or
interconnect attachments in the shared
BBC host project and the virtual
machines and all the service projects
that are attached to the shared network
will then get access to your own trim
via the VPN connection or the
interconnect we are really excited to
announce now the option to create highly
available VPN connections with highly
available VPN you can create two
interfaces on your VPN gateway and you
can connect the pure gateway on your own
friend to these two different interfaces
each of these interfaces gets a
different IP address and this allows
redundancy in your connection to your
on-prem network you can either use
highly available VPN and active active
mode in which case you are advertising
the routes from your own trim using the
same menu on the same priority and you
would need to use the same base priority
as well when advertising those routes to
your V PC and in this case they're out
both the tunnels will be used and the
traffic will be ecmp hashed over both
the tunnels or you can use it an
active/passive moon where one of the
tunnels is used violet as a and when we
figure out that the connectivity is down
then we fall back to the other tunnel
this basically increases the
availability of your VPN connection to
your on-prem by 90% and so in a single
region you get a four nines availability
for connecting to your on-prem network
now the next thing that we have launched
to GA over the past year is cloud NAT no
cloud NAT is a feature that a lot of our
enterprise customers have been asking
for and they're really excited to use
cloud NAT is basically a managed NAT
solution that allows you to configure
access to the internet on your virtual
machines without having to give your
virtual machines public Ivies we
implement outbound not we don't have
lament inbound not and so this increases
the security of your VPC by ensuring
that connections
not be initiated from a malicious user
on the Internet to your virtual machines
running in the cloud cloud 9 basically
scales seamlessly across the ends and
across connections by handling both
static as well as dynamic IP allocation
you can configure not as well in the
share PPC host project in the regions
where you have virtual machines that
need connectivity to the Internet so
let's imagine that you have a package
server that you would like to download
packages from onto your virtual machines
running in your V PC before you can
bootstrap them now after you configure
the nut gateways in your shell BBC host
project the VMS in all the service
projects that are attached to the shared
bpc will be able to access the packet
server using the IPS that are managed by
the NAT gateway one thing that is really
important to mention here is that NAT is
a control beam component it's not a
proxy based solution and so you get the
same bandwidth and performance for your
internet connection as you would if you
were to give public IP s to your VMs so
NAT basically scales really well you
need a single NAT gateway because it's
not a proxy based solution in order to
manage the NAT IP s for thousands of VMs
in that region in your V PC now if you
assign public IP addresses to your VMs
primarily for getting connectivity to
the internet but you also had the added
advantage of being able to SSH to your
VMs using those public IPS then you lose
that capability when you remove public
IPS and when you switch to cloud not
because connections cannot be initiated
from outside the V PC using cloud 9 with
cloud IP and cloud IP is something we
discussed briefly in the context of
global load balanced applications cloud
IP is now extended to have functionality
for TCP forwarding and what this allows
you to do is
to specify I am policies on who has
access to SSS to your VMs and when a
request comes in the proxy will
basically check whether the user has
been granted I am permission to access
to SSH access to the VM and then if that
check passes then the SSH connection
will be wrapped inside HTTPS and then
using TCP forwarding will be sent to the
remote instance running in your V PC now
coming to the next topic how do you
access managed services managed services
can be accessed by using V PC peering so
if you want to get full mesh
connectivity between two V pcs that are
running in clown they may be in
different organizations or the same
organization then you can use vbc
peering there any excited to announce
the general availability of private
service access the private service
access is a managed solution that allows
you to get a private connection to a
managed service and the other really
cool thing that it does is it allows you
as a service consumer to specify a
global IP range and hand this off to the
service provider so that all the sub
networks in the service providers BBC
get carved out of this global IP range
and so as a consumer you are able to
better plan for the IP ranges that are
used for your managed services one of
the really important features that we
have added as functionality to BBC
peering is the ability to access
PRV pcs from your on-prem network and so
you can if you have a pen if you have a
V PC and you are accessing a managed
service might through V PC peering and
you have a VPN connection from your own
Prem to your V PC then you are able to
also access the managed services from
the on-prem via VPN or inter connect to
your V PC the other feature that we have
launched which is now available in beta
is the ability to control custom round
exchanges so let's take a look at all of
these in more detail so let's say you
have two
works the one on the left is the
consumer VPC and the one on the right is
a producer vbc these two are in
different organizations and once you
pair these two bbc's you get full mesh
connectivity between all the virtual
machines in both these V pcs and so you
are able to access the managed service
viens from virtual machines in different
regions in your consumer V PC as well as
in different service projects so
basically you get full mesh connectivity
now let's imagine an example where the
consumer V PC basically has added custom
routes in their routing table so on the
consumer V pcs routing table you can see
the default local routes for the subnets
that are created in the consumer V PC
you can see the peer out for the subnet
that is created in the peer V PC and you
say two additional static routes so one
of them is a static route to the VPN
tunnel so that's basically your outgoing
to the consumers on-prem and there's
another route that is configured to next
hop to a VM so let's say you have an
appliance that is running on the VM on
the peer sign you're able to see the
default local route to the subnet on the
peer VPC and you're also able to see the
peer routes to the subnets that are
added in the consumer VDC however by
default you cannot see the custom routes
that get added in the consumer V PC and
so the route to the VPN as well as the
route to the VM appliance are not
visible in the routing table of the
producer V PC by default with the
ability to exchange custom routes over V
PC peering these routes will now be
visible in the producer BBC and so if
you enable export in the consumer and
you enable import of custom routes on
the producer the producers routing table
will be populated with the static routes
that are defined on the consumer b pc so
here you can see the 10.4 slash 16 will
goes to the peer the consumers on-prem
via VPN as well as the static route 10.5
slash 16 which goes to the VM
clients are now visible in the routing
table of the producer VPC you can
disable this by either disabling export
of custom grounds or by disabling import
of custom routes on the receiving VPC
now both export of custom routes as well
as import of custom routes under sable
by default and so in order to exchange
custom routes you need to enable export
on the sender VPC and enable import on
the receiver VDC now the next topic i'll
be talking about is that of VPC flow
logs now BPC flow logs are basically a
feature that we announced and launched
last year and we have enhanced this
product in order to allow you to have
more control over the flow log size that
gets generated the default aggregation
interval for VPC flow logs is 5 seconds
but now you can configure this and
change it to be anywhere between five
seconds to up to 15 minutes you can also
configure the flow report sampling by
default the sampling is 50% and you can
now configure it to be anywhere between
0 and 100%
so this basically allows you to control
the flow log size that gets generated we
also add a certain metadata to flow logs
and there is now an option to exclude
this metadata and with that I would like
to invite Marshall onstage to share with
us a few recent announcements on
cloudiness Thank You Neha so my name is
Marshall Vale I am the product manager
for cloud DNS here at Google cloud and
so one of the key elements of connecting
your resources together in your VPC is
of course DNS or the domain name system
today I'm going to give you a summary of
those types of capabilities that cloud
DNS provides for your epc along with a
couple of exciting new announcements of
course it all starts with cloud DNS
private zones private zones allows
internal DNS resolution to your private
network
now it's important to keep your internal
resolution to your private networks
because that helps exclude external
parties from discovering information
about the resources of course on your
private networks private zones can be
attached to a single network or multiple
networks in your VPC Armazones also
supports what's called split horizon
which allows you to overlapping public
and private zones so for example you may
have a portal that looks different for
your employees then it looks different
from your customers private zones also
supports I am policies so you can
delegate administration capabilities
edit or view capabilities for your zones
pleased to announce that private zones
is now in general availability also very
excited to announce here at next the
availability of stackdriver logging and
monitoring for your private zones this
allows query logs and counts about
responses to be logged to stackdriver
from there you can course store it
long-term and stackdriver
but you can also use stack drivers
pub/sub capabilities to send that long
to other storage locations such as
bigquery but also on Prem for your owns
storage and analysis tools the query
logs that are recorded are very very
similar to bind logs you're familiar
with stores information such as queue
name or our data but also specific GCP
Cloud DNS things such as project ID or
DNS policies so for for the metrics and
the monitoring that records information
such as serve fails or annex domain
counts and this is all really important
because it helps you debug your DNS
situations in your V PC but also it's
important for security analysis for
threats in your system pleased to
announce that here at next it's now
available in public beta so I've been
talking about cloud DNS services within
your V PC but you also may need to
connect your DNS services from your V PC
to other locations such as on Prem or
even another V PC
so for connecting to on pram we have a
capability called DNS forwarding this
allows bi-directional dns resolution
from your GCP resources to your on-prem
resources now DNS outbound forwarding
allows your GP tcp resources to resolve
hostnames using an on-prem authoritative
server such as bind or Active Directory
DNS inbound forwarding does the opposite
allows your on-prem resources to use
cloud DNS as your authoritative server
you can learn a little bit more about
DNS forwarding and of course your a
variety of hybrid connection options in
the net 204 session DNS forwarding is
currently in public beta also very
excited to announce availability of DNS
peering this allows you to cross DNS
resolution across multiple V pcs let's
look at a couple scenarios
first is say you're a SAS provider and
you want to connect with the V PC and
your consumer the consumer would be
creating a special DNS peering zone that
would connect to the network in the
service providers in V PC and they would
have their own zone
that the final resolution would happen
from or you might want to combine this
with DNS forwarding to create an
architecture way of multiple V pcs that
can use an on-prem authoritative
resolver from there you would make a
single V PC that would be a hub b pc
doing dns forwarding and you have
multiple spoke v pcs that would use dns
peering to connect into the hub vp c dns
peering even supports resolution for
your your internal addresses here at
next-gen s hearing is now available in
public beta so that you can see a
summary of the cloud dns services for
your private zones the wide variety of
flexibility that it supports in your V
PC architectures so with that I'll pass
it back to Nate huh
to give you a summary of what you've
heard today thanks Marshall
so to summarize three main takeaways
that we would like you to you know focus
on from our presentation is that V pcs
are global in nature they are built on
top of a global network backbone and you
are assured that the traffic basically
never leaves the private net the network
backbone you get access to all of your
compute and storage resources globally
and privately so you don't have to
assign public IPS to your virtual
machines in order to access managed
Google services like cloud storage
you're able to configure your global
network once you are able to associate
network policies with this network and
you are also able to centrally create
and manage the network in your
organization while allowing your
organization to scale to hundreds or
even thousands of developers or
development teams security comes first
with Cloud V PC you can apply network
layer firewall rules for specifying
security within your VP see these
firewall rules are stateful and
connection tracked you can specify cloud
armor security policies in order to
apply rules at that get enforced at the
edge of our network for your
load-balanced applications and you can
also use V PC service controls in order
to mitigate the risk of data
exfiltration DPC features are basically
integrated with start rival logging and
now with V PC flow logs and Fargo
logging it is really easy to monitor V
pcs with that I would like to invite ed
onstage to share with us Cardinal health
story on how they deploy and use V pcs
thanks
I should start by saying this is a
really great session I've actually
watched it a couple times so for those
on video you might want to go over it a
couple times in cardinal health were a
fortune 500 company and we have used a
lot of the features that you heard today
we're a global enterprise and so we have
services running all over primarily our
first deployments in GCP have been
within the United States but we have
plans in designs to fully go global and
we provision a lot of that in our
networks our business objectives
are in adopting cloud is to largely be
quick to market be able to adopt
different technologies very quickly and
be very cost effective obviously in all
our businesses we want to try and save
money and so we're always interested in
trying to be the most effective with
every dollar we spend the other thing
that we have to do is we have to make
sure that we're protecting all our
healthcare information there's lots of
regulations in various different
countries about health care information
so protecting our customer information
is very key to us as far as being having
agility and being able to be flexible
and speed the market we want to try and
move the our shared services traditional
structure more into a DevOps model where
development teams can provision their
own services but we still need to make
sure it's secure so we need to provide
techniques and and capabilities where
they can be very agile very flexible
without having to say mother mae-eye if
you will and but still keep all those
guardrails in place so they don't do
something that would be compromising to
our customer data or to the enterprise
and of course I mentioned the cost
effectiveness obviously that's a key
aspect so what we chose to do early on
was we created to host projects so we
have to host projects that basically do
all the network things
so that what that does is for our
application teams they don't have to
think about all those Network pieces all
the interconnects and all that kind of
stuff is hidden from them and then we
have hundreds of service projects that
sit on top of that and they use these to
host projects these we have one for
production one for non production each
one of those have multiple different VP
C's and those service projects are then
allocated or authorized to be used by
various different development teams
those development teams then are able to
utilize the network one thing that if
you're in the network world and you've
talked to a lot of developers for any
length of time you'll find that you
start talking about routes and BGP and
firewalls and all's in their eyes glaze
over and they don't want to hear about
it I don't know about you but I've run
into a lot of that so we try and make it
very very easy for our consumers our
consumers being the development staff
that are actually helping the business
and in that regard there's lots of need
for training there's lots of need for
documentation and there's a continual
process in our company it's very large
and we have lots of people coming -
going all the time so we're constantly
doing this education over and over again
documentation training videos in-house
webcasts and that kind of thing that we
do are very very key to our strategy
there we also have to make sure we have
all the governance controls in place
both proactive and reactive governance
controls that's really critical to a
success in a highly regulated industry
such as we so the value of the host
projects again is I have small number of
Network experts a very small number of
experts that know how all this
networking thing works so all the air
connects the VPN tunnels BPC peering how
all that gets put together all that
physics that's behind the scenes we try
and make it simple and easy to consume
we have a few centralized appliances
that we use I gave a presentation
earlier this week about how we use some
centralized appliances to do some of the
more traditional security perimeter
work that you might expect in large
enterprise that's been around for a long
period of time and we're moving to the
cloud we have a lot of technologies that
we have to bring with us we also have
need at times to create a separate
subnet say for instance there's a
service project that they have a very
specific need so we can create a subnet
just for them and allow just that
service project access to that subnet so
therefore nobody else knows about it
just a swarm service project that's
pretty powerful we've used that a couple
times
as far as firewall rule management again
this is one of those governance controls
we use firewall augie extensively that
was a great feature that we looked
forward to and have been using it since
the day ik was released or available to
us we we've been using it for a while
but we use service accounts so the goal
here is that I have vmn stand say
another vm instance and it's in my own
service project we allow the target and
the source to be the same and we allow
ingress and egress rules for those so
they can talk to each other so it's wide
open any so I have a collection if you
will within my service project I can
grant that if I want to go between two
service projects then I go service
account two service account what that
does is it gives us pretty good
segmentation across the different
projects and pretty tight controls in
that regard when we have a standard
pattern like a north-south pattern for
example internet an internal web server
an internal web server is a standard 80
and 443 allowed in from the RFC 19
address space and so if that's the case
then we allow them to put on a network
tag this has been pre-approved by
security and you apply that network tag
only to the VM instances where that
applies so not everybody gets it but now
as a DevOps team I don't have to go to
the network team to do a firewall rule I
just apply that tag I get those firewall
rules in some cases we have network tags
that apply both at ingress egress and
routing rules
for example so or egress we use that for
to get outside through some security
appliances for some certain use cases so
we do it that was based on routing and
firewall rules as well and then we also
have cloud functions that actually
monitor some of these firewall rules so
we don't do anything really dangerous
this is the reactive and so if somebody
for some reason creates a firewall rule
that was not supposed to be the case we
shut that down within seconds I'm guilty
of doing that I open I create a firewall
rule it was a zero zero zero I was doing
in a very specific use case the function
caught me closed it down I reenable did
a couple times I'm like oh I know it's
wrong I didn't add myself to the exclude
list so so that was a good test it
actually worked just what we wanted it
to be the value of the service projects
again is for the DevOps teams so a
DevOps team can actually build all their
resources as you know a project is about
four authorization as well as four
[Music]
costing in our case we have costing
based on projects so with that we can
delegate the accountability down to a
DevOps team and let them move on their
own
again we advertise only say advertise
it's grant the permission to only
selected subnets to these projects so
rather than seeing all the VP C's that
we built running seeing all the subnets
that we built we only advertise selected
subnets so say for instance your project
wants to run in in Europe and only in
Europe I'm not going to show you any of
the subnets that are in the United
States same way in the United States or
in Asia whatever so that that's very
very capable very very powerful to us so
then the developers don't have to start
thinking about all these network things
it's us central one or u.s. East one
that's a pretty simple thing developers
can deal with that ok
we also have an organizational policy
that prohibits the creating of any
instances with an external IP address
obviously the net
capability was a powerful feature in
that regard as well okay so to sort of
summarize showing on this picture we
have multiple different V pcs each one
these you know global network XY and Z
we have different V pcs and those are
provision in the host project within any
service project I may expose only one or
two subnets and in this case service
project B and service project a are
communicating to each other from
different regions they can be global
over the Google backbone and that all
works and the firewall rules that you
see on there I have illustration of
three of them the first one is the
internal web server so that's a network
tag based rule so if I put that on my
server I can exceed 80 and 443 traffic
in my decision as a development devops
person and then the middle one is the
service count to service count so if
you're in that same service account you
have ingress egress to all your peers
and that's an any kind of rule and then
the last one is service project to
service projects so we're using as much
as we can service account to service
count and that gives us that
point-to-point communication well that
concludes my portion of the presentation
I'll turn it back over to Nia so we
might not have too much time for
questions but we'll be available outside
this room for Q&A so thanks so much
everyone for coming and you know see you
again next year
[Music]